it is also possible
it goes from the VVD fraction
thank you chairman
and thanks also to the State Secretary
for the fed debate
i think we
exchange the debate on debate again
that we all hope
and watching every time
of how we do this task
can accelerate and simplify even further
and also 1 number of colleagues have motions there
about submitted
but I still want to emphasize that
I really see it too
Which
the officials who are working hard on it
also the State Secretary
and I think we too here as a room
try each other every time
achieve that too
so let's do that too
holding each other
because only then will we move that step forward
so that we also have those parents
can help
that said I have heard 1 more room
the deliberation
noting that there are now several
damage in recovery routes for victims and being open
whereas generosity
treatment of the parent's story
and explainability and transparency
are important principles and conditions
at the damage routes
after the integral assessment
whereas it is good that victims
can choose which one
route to recovery suits them best
and their personal situation
and in this way they themselves have more control
get over their trajectory
whereas it is important that
despite the differences in the approach
the results of the processes
should not lead to inexplicable differences
result and it must be clear to victims
what the pros and cons of the different routes
the government requests
therefore make an effort
about the pros and cons of the different routes
at the front
communicate clearly to victims
and to enter into consultation with CBS
sga and the direction route
to prevent
that inexplicable differences arise
the results and proceeds to the order of the day
that was co-signed by colleague Inge van Dijk
and hanneke van derwerf fine
I bark for 5 minutes
and then we will listen to the Secretary of State